well welcome everybody and good
afternoon it's the Tuesday April the
30th 2019 session in our series on
entrepreneurship and Asian high-tech
industries
I'm Richard Asher I direct the u.s.
Asian Technology Management Center we're
very happy to present this series
especially with support from the member
companies in our industry and foliat
industry affiliates program so thanks to
that support we'll have some
refreshments at the end of the session
today and hope you'll stay afterward and
get to meet our speaker and get to talk
with each other some more so today we
have a second presentation looking at
the situation in India first we had
looked at it from the standpoint of
competitiveness and kind of economic
theory a couple of weeks ago today unda
lighted that our speaker is bringing to
us the technical investor serial
entrepreneur perspective dr. Rajesh
Gupta got his PhD in computer science at
Stanford so I'm also very happy to
welcome back on alum and he is the
co-founder and Managing Partner of
Hylian ventures which is investing in
India and it was really one of the very
first domestic venture capital firms to
invest in that country he is a serial
entrepreneur he founded two successful
companies tavant technologies and also
jungly which was acquired by Amazon
correct and he as a lot of venture
capital investors are doing now he's on
the board of a number of companies some
of his prior investments include things
like Flipkart so maybe we should ask you
to pay for those refreshments today also
red bus which was a successful Indian
company acquired by a Chinese company
and he has been a Kauffman fellow which
is a very prestigious kind of venture
capitalist training program sponsored by
the Kauffman Foundation and he
he has authored several patents
publications and also a book by MIT
press so let me get out of the way and
ask dr. Gupta to give us some prepared
remarks thank you very much for coming
guys thank you thank you thanks thanks a
lot everybody for being here and my
request would be that please feel free
to interrupt me at pretty much any point
in time that way it's more fun and
especially if you disagree it is even
more fun because a lot of this is a
matter of opinion there are some facts
which we'll try and keep as close to
facts as possible despite the current
trends in the world at large but the
opinions for sure are subject to debate
and definitely wonderful to see you so
definitely have a colleague's a jangly
so it's it's nice as here after many
years so the points about me that might
be relevant I try to do two jobs didn't
succeed worked at IBM and an Oracle had
wonderful bosses didn't lasted either
place so I became an entrepreneur more
because I didn't know how to survive in
a large company rather than because I
had a clear point of view and what I
wanted to do and this will come in later
I've been investing in India for about
20 years
the first investment was in 1999 which
was as an angel and then as an
institutional investor been investing in
India since 2006 also have had offices
in India and that have started and ran
since about 1998 so about 20 odd years
of exposure to India and I'm a
generalist so done services services for
those of you who don't know are labor
arbitrage companies India has a lower
cost of living companies like Infosys
TCS even IBM has 100,000 people in India
so done several of those kinds of
companies a consumer internet and make
my trip is a OTA like an Expedia so to
speak and also some enterprise companies
including companies like upwork which
does a marketplace for people to develop
code again overseas Helion started in
2006 and we've raised six hundred
million dollars across three different
funds and we've invested it pretty much
all we are not raising any more money so
as a on
going fund the funders not be making new
investments we are in the process of
garnishing whatever investments we had
made and we have about 60 companies that
we have invested in over the course of
the last 12 years
they include make my trip as your power
which is a solar power generation
company big basket which is the delivers
group they deliver groceries at home so
like instacart except that they control
the inventory also Ola cabs which
competes with uber in India
uber and Ola are somewhat head to head
or neck to neck rather the works part
which is based here and I'll get into
some of more some of these as we go on
so a little bit of history about India
venture most of it is concurrent with
some seminal events that have happened
at the economic level or at the national
level so for example the first wave of
BC's which would have been circa 95 96
soon after liberalisation happened in
India so India used to be notorious for
what is known as the license raj and in
the early 90s one of the prime ministers
came by and opened up the economy a
great deal and soon after that the first
set of venture firms came around thank
you so much my memory extends there we
have better data and please keep jumping
in neither of the funds actually Walden
was started by a gentleman who lives
here le bouton it was even precursor by
Bill Draper who started Saturday and
ICICI still go strong it's one of the
longest lasting venture firms in India
by long shock the second set of VC firms
that came about were like an echo of the
dot-com boom here like in most of the
parts of the world in the air to said ah
the Internet is coming pretty much
everybody from the second set is gone
except for two that I know of and please
take these as indicative numbers it's
not exhaustive
of whom I have become extremely
successful but as private equity firms
Westbridge and Chris capital phenomenal
track record of investing and very smart
move away from venture into private
equity the third set of or the third
coming so to speak which has resulted in
the more stable ecosystem that we see
today was in the back of the credibility
of China having become a destination
where a lot of people raise money and a
lot of people made money and this was
part of the wave that I also
participated in in fact the fundraising
experience was very interesting where I
had been pretty much thrown out of every
limited partners office limited partners
are people who invest in VC's till press
articles started talking about India
being the next China and within a matter
of two months we had successfully raised
a hundred and forty million dollars
which of course causes serious
introspection because it was clearly not
me that was getting funded it was the
person who wrote the Wall Street Journal
article that was really momentous or
important for the funding event but that
was the third coming of the Indian
venture scene and this is where the bulk
of the firms that got created have not
only survived but a several of them are
thriving so they were largely three
kinds of firms that got started
one was foreign visas because everybody
was kind of touching and feeling and
figuring out should we do there should
we not do this or bunch of people were
flying in and out that included people
like battery Columbia Foundation kleiner
perkins all the people who are flying in
and out have stopped those that
committed to put feet on the street have
survived and they include people like
Excel Lightspeed matrix these all have
not only well established presence here
in the valley but they also have their
established presence in India and the
third genre was the ones that abaca
pardon that was the foreign folks the
second were the corporate folks which
today include aunt is Ali Baba's
financial services arm Google Intel
Qualcomm info edge is an Indian company
Tencent so between us majors and china
company is pretty much all corporate
venture capital in India
rounded four and then there are domestic
firms these are people who only have
presence in India of which we are one
and there are others Gallery Nexus safe
and I'm sure I've omitted several names
so no offenses intended of course yes
corporate funds in fridge is one of
those there are also people like VIP
rogue but they are more run out of the
family office rather than the
corporation and I'm missing but the
point being that you can count them on
one hand even if it's not like yes
discuss it right away so the question
was why did the people who were flying
in and out why did that not sustain
which is by the way an excellent point
because it repeats itself in every
geography it showed up in Israel it
showed up in the UK and so and so forth
one is in the beginning considered at a
scouting mission where people instead of
actually hiring somebody are investing
the energy to figure out is this worth
doing or not so some people separated
out in that way another set of people
who did not make it because of the 2008
bust where the firm's that were flying
in and out those that were not very
strong were told by their investors that
they need to first mind their core
business at home as opposed to get
distracted by this new shiny thing ten
thousand miles away the same investors
were encouraging people to try out this
new shiny thing two years ago but when
hard times come then everybody hunkers
down and figures out what is my
coordinating and stick to it so 2008 was
the seminal point where a lot of the
flying folks were shut out of the market
and because they had to choose where
they were investing dollars okay
continuing on the timeline when I moved
to India 2006 everybody believed that
the Internet is just around the corner
or the adoption of the internet I beg
your pardon the Internet was very much
there large adoption of the internet was
just around the corner many a year was
spent wringing our hands waiting for
users to grow
but nothing would happen what changed
the scene was the iPhone as soon as the
smartphone arrived while the iPhone did
not come to India a whole bunch of
Cheaper knock-offs did actually motivate
the telcos to start meaningfully invest
in data services so 2009 2010 was
watershed in terms of the number of
Internet users that really took off a
flip card for example saw traction then
as did a whole bunch of other companies
in that year so that was one very
interesting event from the perspective
the growth professor - sure was asking
me when do these venture funds raise
money from foreign investors or are
there domestic investors that trend
started in about 2012 odd and please
treat these numbers as as indicative the
Indian corporation started putting
putting money into venture funds as did
some pools of capital that traditionally
stay away so for example retirement
funds are a big contributor to venture
capital in the u.s. in India there are
very few retirement funds by and large
the maturity of what kinds of asset
classes people invest in is much earlier
in India than it is here and it takes
time for people who manage retirement
fronts in particular to be told that go
take this risk otherwise they are told
to be a lot more conservative with their
capital that movement has started now
for the NOC last six to seven years but
the bulk of the capital comes from
people like Stanford Harvard the
not-for-profit foundations wealthy
individuals who pull capital together
and invest in venture funds that would
probably account for and this is a guess
more than 95 percent of the capital that
is invested in the venture industry in
India and a 2018 saw another event which
is Reliance launched a service called
geo where they are pretty much giving
away broadband let's see how the pricing
changes over time and that has
completely redone the face of the
Internet user in India and the most
primary user of that is everybody stands
around in a corner and watches use this
videos and
what are the sociological impacts of
follow that we will discuss them another
time what can be told in very clear
terms is the amount of content
consumption in India right now is just
insane one interesting factoid whatsapp
discovered that every morning at the
time India morning just the good morning
messages that went from one person to
another person accompanied by a video of
them drinking tea or coffee or whatever
the hell they were doing accounted for
double-digit percentages of traffic of
whatsapp every day like clockwork
between 6:00 a.m. and 7:00 a.m. India
time so it's that wacky that you have
double-digit percentages of traffic over
and baibe and mostly junk and that
number is is continuing to rise and that
raises very interesting questions which
will discuss vernacular content plays
and things like that and how does that
play out over time okay shall we move on
some characteristics of the India market
one its open
and I'm contrasting that in particular
with a nod to China which chose to take
a close market approach and this debate
still goes on in India and I will tell
you why it is still a debate and it's
not a clear answer as to which is a
better better answer several people who
I knew who were fans of the open market
approach are today talking about why we
might be better served to actually close
it down or at least throttle it some and
everything in between so it's an open
market English thanks to the British is
reasonably widespread not everybody
speaks English but the net penetrates
India slower than English penetrates
India so it's a interesting question as
to whether vernacular will ever be an
interesting area but especially when you
look at where the dollars are it is
directly correlated to English skills so
for anybody who's looking at things from
an economic perspective most of the
popular websites in India do not even
have a local language rendition they are
practically entirely English and please
correct me if I'm wrong I don't think
Flipkart has a local version neither
does make my trip and they do not okay
thank you
but also like Peter language is running
and how old would that be so you're
right like he said okay thank you so
much
so as the net is penetrating you will
find more of this language happening
glitches is very popular and there is
serious connection to the US evidenced
by people like myself and there are what
at least four five million expats in
India in the US a bigger burden and
because several of them come from the
tech industry that is where between
healthcare and tech that defines most of
the Indian expats a lot of the US
products found their use in India very
quickly especially those that had viral
components hotmail for example which
some of you might not remember it is
today Microsoft open email offering
about in 1998 from here
hot mails largest set of email ids have
always been from India and that was one
of the mainstays for both the absence of
a business model and presence of large
amounts of traffic
so this spread from the US is what
defines or explains why Facebook Amazon
Netflix Google and of that Facebook and
Google first are the dominant equivalent
platforms in India also there is no room
for anybody else and the few people who
have tried have all kind of figured out
but relatively quickly that this is not
a game they can play Amazon and Netflix
of course is a different game it's a
very conscious execution game as opposed
to a viral propagation of stuff so they
fall in a different category but yet
Fang is the dominant player for these
classes of businesses in India also this
is one of the reasons why this debate
shows up as to whether or not one should
start closing off certain parts yes yes
building Netflix and Amazon all paid
video is currently taken care of
you know small in terms of revenue when
you compare it to these guys and then
you look at how the spread is the rate
of growth it's even more scary
especially Amazon is continuing to do
what it does which is cross subsidize
yeah okay cloud infra is dominated by US
companies in fact we wonder sometimes
jokingly whether the Indian Army's
machine learning models whatever they
are can be shut down by convincing
Amazon to turn off its service for an
hour or two there is not a locally run
data center plus software infrastructure
on top of it where you can reliably run
do machine learning for example among
several other things there are local
Rackspace equivalent companies but
they're very much that they're hosting
players they are not full stack
infrastructure players and that space is
also dominated by Indian companies and
now Alibaba has started a fairly serious
push to get its software stack run
inside of an Indian company Paytm is
that company to try and offer quote
unquote a native cloud infrastructure
stack but it is far from native so that
is another very interesting thing to
just park in the back of your head as
one looks at opportunities why are some
of these things happening because
capital and technology is significantly
stronger than geographic boundaries
Amazon spends multiple billion dollars
per annum in subsidizing the customer
acquisition and sales in India
technology stacks once you build them if
you look at the stack at the scale of
what Facebook operates Google operates
are very very hard to replicate unless
you invest large amounts of money and a
lot of time in doing that these are two
things that have really helped their
technology intensive or capital
intensive businesses to continue to
dominate in India also the enterprises
on the other hand so this is mostly
consumer facing other than the cloud
infrastructure and enterprise facing if
you look at enterprises themselves what
are the equivalents of the Procter &
Gamble's the general electric
the powered utility companies here these
are buyers of IT if you look at the
buyers of IIT in India they spend a much
smaller percentage of their overall
budget on IT their early to this game so
when one of their CEOs goes out and
makes a buying decision she or he is
much better equipped and much better
served by saying I'm buying IBM
proverbial IBM nobody buys IBM but so
you find Salesforce s a PSAP does I
think a billion dollars of revenue in
India Oracle they all sell very
effectively in the Indian enterprise
startups on the other hand have a
terrible time selling to Indian
enterprises both because of this
conservatism and also because when you
are early in the technology adoption
cycle
you don't want innovation you first want
efficiency and automation which comes
from off-the-shelf solutions all if your
problem is not being solved by an
off-the-shelf solution of which we are
beginning to some see some things HR for
example or taxation the rules are
different enough that you don't end up
using a u.s. solution therefore there
are homegrown solutions that are getting
traction but in places that can be
transplanted the enterprise's choose to
buy us software and that also will
change over time local companies are
more successful in categories that are
either regulated or that have physical
touch so you look at telecom if you look
at FinTech by the way financial
technology in India coming to the u.s.
makes one feel like one has gone back to
the stone Age's we are busy writing
checks to each other if I want to
transfer money to somebody else from a
bank account it's not possible so
financial technologies and actually a
whole bunch of stuff in the telecom
stack also things are significantly
further ahead because one started late
and therefore one has built much better
systems in place than for example a
place like the u.s. in those kinds of
categories and now increasingly in full
stack plays full stack meaning instead
of selling something to so let's take
lending here for those of you who are
familiar with a lending club or a
cabbage they're saying instead of trying
to sell a solution to a bank
I will both become a pseudo Bank I will
land I will do risk assessment I will
basically solve the whole problem a
number of companies like this in India
are doing extremely well in logistics in
financial technologies in food and that
instead of teaching an old dog a new
trick you basically become the dog and
the trick and the ringmaster the whole
shooting match and that also is useful
in another way in a market where there
isn't that much money to take you take
all the margins from the top to the
bottom and that makes the business a lot
more viable okay so a bunch of companies
in that space vernacular as I mentioned
growing quickly and as the gentleman
there mentioned its penetrating what was
otherwise English also the money behind
vernacular is still an open question
because that is typically associated
with folks who do not have as much
spending power all who are not as
familiar with technology to spend that
money even though they have the power
and it's a combination of those two
things but that again is a matter of
time one other dynamic is the cost of
building technology significantly lower
there than it is here I don't know how
many of you hired people here and those
of you are going to be in the job market
to the tech industry my congratulations
it's impossible to hire people here
without paying starting salaries of
north of $100,000 and if by any chance
you have deep learning on your resume we
start with the quarter million dollars
independent of whether or not you know
how to spell it so it is just it's very
very hard to build a lot of these
companies here if you need serious
technology that cost in India goes
anywhere from a tenth to a third and
it's not all a bed of roses
and we will talk about that also but a
number of enterprise software companies
are coming out exactly because of that
dynamic if you can iterate a version of
a product with half a million dollars as
opposed to five it gives you multiple
shots at goal and therefore you can take
both raise smaller amounts of capital
take it longer and avoid dying if you
get it wrong and you've blown all the
cash that you
had all of those dynamics play in favor
of these enterprise software companies
okay so kind of broken up the market
into a two by two despite not having an
MBA so there is one the the columns are
are you going after the India market or
are you going after the foreign market
and the foreign market I am
predominantly using the US as a proxy
the u.s. accounts for 30-40 percent of
every kind of spend in the world so
using that as a proxy and along the rows
the first several rows above the yellow
line our consumer slash full-stack
companies and below that is enterprise
okay so there are two quadrants that are
pretty much empty there are very few if
any consumer companies that are going
after foreign markets out of India so
the consumer companies are all looking
at the India market which also makes
sense you understand the consumer it's
much more local the nature of the beast
is very different changes very quickly
so if you're local you can actually
relate to the consumer and move much
faster the domestic enterprise market is
also pretty much non-existent it's
dominated by also by the way the stuff
in blue italics and underlined is a
foreign company the stuff in black is an
India company born in India so the
enterprise market locally is either
dominated by foreign companies si P
Amazon Microsoft Oracle but there is
very little local activity so we will
spend our time in these other two
quadrants where there is more to talk
about consumer media as we discussed is
dominated pretty much entirely by
foreign companies there are now some
local vernacular plays share chat stuff
like that but even there Chinese
companies have very serious presence
food which is again high-touch is a to
large companies Zomato and swiggy and
it's a very interesting sector because
there are lots of double income no kids
extremely hard to drive from home to
work so you get
the infrastructure issues are a
recurring theme as we go through this
traffic is if you think 101 is bad you
ain't seen nothing yet you got to go
hang out in Bangalore and Mumbai and you
will be glad to drive on 101 so when you
combine working hours with logistics
things like food and other convenience
which is delivered at home becomes a
very interesting space so food has grown
like a weed the unit economics by the
way will part for a moment we will
discuss that as a standalone the
category for those of you who are
thinking about India retail we know our
Flipkart and Amazon Flipkart is now
owned by Walmart again all discount
driven by the way the unit economics for
pretty much every consumer facing
business in India make no sense they
lose money and this is practically every
business the exceptions can be counted
the rule is they lose money at a
transaction level I am NOT talking
marketing cost of customer acquisition I
am talking about here is a box somebody
will touch it to ship it out somebody
will carry it the cost of fuel the cost
of the box the cost of the goods versus
the money that you get paid you lose
money we are not talking about the
advertising yet that of course you lose
money but a transaction level all of
them lose money and that is true for
food retail both Amazon Flipkart is true
for uber and Ola on every right they
lose money so that's the recurring theme
for practical business I think there's
some changes that we see in the last two
years which are also growing very fast
the Jewish stood up there for that
succeed or not but things like food
lighting the London market would I in
train Australia and New Zealand Paytm
entering Canada Japan and the one that
you don't have sup there is oil which is
$5 per unicorn which has entered China
China is flowing it's almost equal to
the Inca business thank you so I
actually do believe that even consumer
media plays will come out of India and
we can talk about that later so I
personally started
a few so the future I think is a very
different ballgame but point very well
taken thank you
and for those of you who could not hear
the gentleman he was saying that there
are examples of several companies like
Ola which is a car ride company has gone
overseas there is a hospitality company
which has managed to tails that has gone
overseas and a payment company also yes
like if some things are not making money
their quantities are increasing margins
are decreasing and you said at the
transaction level they're losing money
and like what like I'm just refreshment
I'm just thinking aloud you hear that at
this point of time it is it like for
example I did not feel that said that
Amazon is going like the Indian market
is like a winner-takes-all like in this
competition between Amazon and Flipkart
in the end whoever has more amount of
capital to burn and Weber and whoever
runs out of capital first is going to
lose and the other one takes the whole
market but in a sense aren't we setting
up the Indian market the expectations
too high and like fill the building will
them will the market even use this kind
of products when the prices increase
like for example I'm like just an
example if your car runs out of Walmart
runs out of capital and like Amazon is
is like jealous player so I'll be
setting up the expectations too high for
the market of the consumer so the
consumer will eventually have to pay the
price of the product that is being given
right now and this is meant in jest it
is a large amount of wealth movement
from the wealthy in the US Europe and
Asia to the consumer in India via the
VC's that is one way of looking at
normalization of standards of living a
process that is going on so yes it will
reverse at some point in time the bet
that most of these companies are making
is that behavior will change so that it
will make it irreversible and even
though you might find that some set of
people will step back the vast majority
of people begin to pay for convenience
so a couple of interesting factoids in
China they used to be rampant piracy of
content once the per capita income went
above a certain threshold
people started valuing the convenience
of not having to do all the tours and so
and so forth
to get around this nuisance of so China
saw the levels of content piracy
literally fall off a cliff
very very commensurate with the increase
of a per capita numbered beyond a
certain and an economist had explained
to me why that number in of course
hindsight made a lot of sense so there
is a fair bit of speculation on at least
two counts one is that as the GDP keeps
going up and per capita income going up
people pay more for convenience than
they would otherwise because the cost of
convenience becomes acceptable a given
disposable income that is one and the
second is some behaviors become
irreversible so for example if you look
at Ola
or uber the ride-sharing stuff I think
that behavior is irreversible if
tomorrow these companies start running
the business on profit at least I would
bet and this is an opinion will the
business shrink the answer is yes will
it still be meaningfully large I think
the answer is absolutely yes because it
is a behavior that has led to several
people that I know getting rid of their
cars and these are people who can afford
a driver so we are not talking of
somebody who's just not interested in
driving themselves largely because if a
new balance of both cost of capital and
your balance of convenience you're
better off
parking is a nuisance where do you put
that car even if you have it when you
read somebody's home so several of these
will fall in and that is the bet that by
the way most of these people are making
what do you mean so would Netflix be a
product or service the reason I'm asking
is because that is a very profound
question that you raised which is which
causes consternation not only within
this context but
let's use a couple of examples and and
see if we can find companies like that
sure okay
okay good Elan musk existing that is so
thank you and it is a more reflection of
my bias and it is an act of omission so
they are there and I will quickly talk
to it and I just neglected to put them
here because I didn't think about it so
with you and let's address first your
first question which definitely is worth
addressing and then let's talk about the
IP stuff maybe outside because that is a
more interesting debate so there are a
whole bunch of companies that are doing
medical devices there are a number of
evey companies there are at least I beg
your pardon I can think of at least six
companies that are doing scooters or
electric vehicles or variations thereof
and several of them are doing well there
is a very interesting robotics company
called gray orange which has started
building their house robotics for
managing ecommerce warehouses and stuff
and they are also seriously doing very
well so there are a number of those
companies and because I don't invest in
those areas I completely forgot about it
my apologies I'll be happy to give you
more data about it if you're interested
drop me a note and I will compile some
of that and get it together to you but
there is a number of amount there the
healthcare stuff in particular is very
interesting because there is no FDA
scrutiny at the level at which you see
in this country you have the ability to
actually iterate and produce product at
a much faster pace now the folks who are
very staunch defendants of the FDA will
make an argument that does that mean we
will treat other human beings at a
guinea-pig level there's a spectrum of
this there are well-intentioned people
who will not abuse that privilege just
as there are well-equipped people here
who abuse the privilege despite the FDA
because you can work around FDA you will
be amazed at the statistics that the FDA
uses to say yes or no for example you
can have 99 failures but the to success
what are counted for getting an approval
so anybody who believes that that is a
very interesting conservative system has
another thought coming but there is a
whole bunch of stuff happening in
medical devices because the opportunity
to take product to market is
significantly larger the number of
served people is significantly lower and
the barrier to entry is significantly
lower also so good point so I don't
think we should treat these as hard
boundaries especially when we start
looking at Southeast Asia and the Middle
East there there is a lot of back and
forth also numbers are not yet
meaningful though because but again
point we're taking yes forty minutes are
done so it's not necessary to go through
this as long as we are service companies
in some ways they're either marketplaces
etc but effectively a version of offline
services in digital format right what we
see what are you fighting against so
this is the exit picture and this is
going to be impossibly hard to read my
apologies this is courtesy of Bain &
Company because they had collected the
data so I just cut and paste and I the
report is available publicly
if you look for Bain and IBC I this
here's the Indian Venture Capital
Association you will find this report
and it has a lot more data with a lot
more intelligent commentary than what
you'll get from me so this is the exit
picture what it says is that in 2014
there was one point three billion
dollars of exit that grew to two point
three billion in two
thousand 15 that came down to 1.4 in
went up to about 4 in 2017 and then
jumped to 20 in 2018 so 20 was an
outlier that was when Walmart bought
Flipkart so if we look at even remove
that by the way this is the business of
outliers so throwing outliers will leave
you with a useless graph in this
exercise but for a moment let's remove a
flip card we can see that the exits have
kind of gone from very little numbers to
at least repeatably two to three to four
billion dollars per annum if you also
over leave another factor on top of this
which is that the venture business is
about 2006
so about 13 years old it takes 8 to 10
years for companies to get to a place
where they become interesting in
conjunction it's a small market by
definition which is growing large so if
you look at the dollar sizes India is a
two trillion dollar GDP give or take the
u.s. is what eighteen or fourteen
eighteen yeah my recollection was
eighteen somewhere fourteen to eighteen
so somewhere between 7 to 9 times larger
and when you overlay disposable income
on top on top of it
the opportunity to create value is very
seriously tied to disposable income
otherwise the bulk of your money will
get spent in just surviving so that
equation becomes even more skewed what
the VC is including people like myself
are betting on already if you see the
the this is an interesting curve that
within twelve years of the creation of
an industry the venture industry in the
u.s. is at least 50 years old Saturday
was started in 1967 and it wasn't even
the first venture firm so we are in an
era where things move much faster we are
early in that game there are 1.2 billion
people in the country and growing so
there are only one of two outcomes
either the country explodes or implodes
or it makes progress there is nothing
else in the in the middle in my view
because you can't open up a Pandora's
box show people wonderful advertising
tell them you deserve
have a Rolex watch and a good pair of
shoes and then tell them no sorry bad
luck and they will either kill each
other or they will figure out a way are
to get out of this so either you have to
be an optimist or a pessimist there is
no sitting on the fence as far as this
particular equation is concerned in my
view so you have a whole bunch of people
betting on the fact that maybe a
long-lasting civil war is not the the
most likely scenario and therefore this
will grow the amount of money that is
being deployed is not that large which
is one of the other things to keep in
mind so this is the amount of money that
is being raised if we see industry okay
so this is what has been invested in
India this is only ventured by the way
this doesn't cover late-stage the 2016
number is three billion which came down
to 1 billion in 17 and in 18 it's about
2.3 billion so if you are putting in
steady-state you are putting in 2 or 3
you're beginning to get 2 or 3 out which
correspond to when the numbers are much
smaller looks like something is working
does that help
when you already know that it's a loss
making thank you so what are some of the
things that one looks for so in most
consumer companies one ends up looking
for engagement and do people come back
time and time again so after you've got
them once will they keep using your
product because if they're engaged then
you will figure out no because
engagement is the next level metric of
eyeballs eyeballs is counting how many
people have come without paying
attention to whether or not they are
actually doing something on your side
[Music]
engagement is somewhere in between at
the same time it doesn't mean eyeballs
that is a little too simplistic and we
can spend many hours around this because
it is a well-defended
and it can be backed up by data so it's
not just an opinion
examples of engagement would be when
Facebook was not monetizing people were
still coming and spending endless
doing useless stuff which was have my
apologies but that is my view it was
clear that if they're going to spend two
hours you will always be able to pick
that pocket for a few cents at some
point in time so if you have engagement
now do you force engagement do you buy
engagement do I give you a $5 coupon
every time to come here and do something
there are shades in between also so for
example discounting in e-commerce begins
to look like eyeballs not engagement if
people are coming of their own volition
and they're not being in scented on the
next transition you're not next
transaction you begin to move down the
path of engagement so that is one metric
that people measure growth is another
one which everybody loves with or
without it's nuances that is the
wonderful trick how to raise money burn
some capital for three months show
inordinate growth and somebody will come
along so that is another metric which a
lot of people look for significantly
more advanced than engagement so just
talking about growth in the capital
value of the company growth in sales
sorry
growth in number of users thank you very
much thank you which then will translate
to growth in the in the valuation is
what one hopes for which is a mystery
absolutely and then you look for from a
VC perspective how do you get out of
this at some point in time which for a
lot of companies in India is an open
question because the Indian capital
markets back to the graph that he's
referring to the bulk of the money in
India has been made by either investors
selling to other investors which you can
argue is the greater fool theory or
Walmart which can also be argued as a
beautiful but and nevertheless the bulk
of the exits are early stage investors
selling to later stage investors there
are now the beginnings of companies that
are more come
that are going public but that still is
not a very large number of companies
that are that can be digested by the
public markets and that is also a
challenge with the size of the public
public markets themselves so for example
our fund has taken three companies
public on the Nasdaq as opposed to the
Indian stock exchange largely because if
you have a billion dollar company and
you don't have enough liquidity in that
market you can't get out of that company
so on the Nasdaq a billion dollar
company doesn't even have to worry about
will cover you in the way of going of
getting out I don't have enough data so
I will give you a few sample points and
times did something together real time
please jump in as the gentleman there
was pointing out there are several
Indian companies that have started
venturing out in my view too early and
part of it it depends upon who's selling
and how you're selling or whether you
count number of users they all very
radically because a user in an overseas
market
is often worth 10 times the user in the
domestic market so when you look at
yield per user for several of these
companies like for example two of our
companies sell in Southeast Asia one
sells payment solutions the other sells
gifting cards for one customer we
literally get ten times the money that
we get in India so one driver for these
overseas market are companies that are
looking to say okay I got all my systems
in place now I need to monetize all of
this in terms of whether or not the
investors value them I think it varies
radically
the thing that people do look for is a
dominant position in the India market if
you don't have a dominant position there
then please don't start wandering around
because then it is more like running
away from a problem rather than having
conquered this and therefore expanding
your horizons if I'm making sense so
that is at least a cursory dynamic that
that I would point to and dr. - just
tell us when we are out of time or we
will pack up accordingly I do want you
to be able to get through what you're
trying to get through so in the
enterprise space I won't touch upon the
services space because that I think most
of you are probably aware of the fact
that that business has been going on for
Infosys started in 83 I'm so at least 36
years for that one company and a whole
bunch of others and that trend continues
with new forms of companies so let's
just deal with b2b software companies so
there are now a few companies that are
in the maybe three or four companies
that are in the 100 million dollar
revenue number in India serving the
global market with honest-to-goodness
enterprise class software product fresh
works is one which competes with
Salesforce I'm told druwa has gotten to
those kinds of numbers and there are a
couple of others whose name I'm blanking
out on still small numbers but the whole
b2b business is maybe six or seven years
old and the reason why it ended up
starting out is because there is a fair
bit of technical talent the folks who
are not equipped to do consumer
companies begin to ask hey I want to do
a startup also and if the domestic
market is not interesting why don't I go
to the overseas market there is already
a history of selling albeit services so
there are enough sales people who have
relationships in these companies to at
least get you going and then you figure
out the rhythm of selling product
as different from rhythm of selling
services they are two very distinct
motions and that was the genesis and the
other point that I mentioned very early
on is the cost advantage you can build
an enterprise-class service company for
example one of the companies that I'm on
the board of we've spent four million
dollars to date and we have six million
dollars of recurring annual revenue it's
nearly impossible to get that kind of
number and by the way this is not every
company I'm calling it out because it's
an exception so I have several others
dogs also which we can talk about how
much money is gone and nothing has come
out but this is doable this is not
doable for all practical purposes in the
valley and this is not the only company
I can give you ten examples of companies
in India that have reached 10 million
here are bootstrapped or a couple of
million dollars in because you can get
technical talent in some of those cases
so I think it is a very interesting
growing space big question there is can
you sell effectively sitting in India
the interesting huge change that at
least I am saying is six seven years ago
you could sell maybe a five thousand
dollar product over the phone and that
too in very specific areas you could
sell tech support you could not sell HR
because the buyer was not used to buying
from Indian sounding voice over the
phone today I know several companies
that closed a hundred thousand to one
hundred and fifty thousand dollar deals
only on the phone across a much larger
set of sectors this is not because
somehow India has turned the tide this
is because fundamentally enterprise
buying is moving to inside sales across
the board India just happens to be the
lucky beneficiary of this trend as will
companies from Southeast Asia or any
other non-us geography even companies
here are not travelling to sell they do
inside sales a video conference to
demonstrate the product and the buyer is
getting more and more comfortable across
more and more segments now I think
million under sale will be hard to close
do you want to meet people but the fact
that it has gone from five K to 150 K in
a matter of five years a repeat
is something to to take note of which
comes to your point I don't have a very
optimistic point of view on on those
kinds of businesses unless they're full
stack selling software I think is not a
game that is going to play out in India
in the near future in my view full-stack
absolutely logistics raviga blackbuck
are doing extremely well they're selling
to businesses but I'm putting them in
the full stack category so maybe it
would be good if you continue with your
presentation and then let's do Q&A at
the end cuz we're really getting into
kind of a general conversation at this
point so what are some of the
implications the government is involved
in regulations both some that you can
criticize some that you have to applaud
for example data protection a lot of
leaves are being taken out of the GDP
our book some of the concerns are around
the fact that if you have and forgive my
use of the word near monopolistic
businesses and I would put Google Amazon
in that category at this point in time
control all your consumer data how do
you guard against not only the thread
that comes out of a company but that
comes out of a foreign company
there are move data to kinds of
initiatives that there must be a copy of
the data within the geographic
boundaries of India it can't be sitting
all in a data center in Oregon so there
are mandatory rules that are being
passed around this that people are
adjusting now keep in mind most digital
laws even in the u.s. are either
evolving or need to all further India is
further behind the curve on all of those
and therefore the fact that these
regulations are getting refined should
not be a surprise one is learning at the
level of policymaking and then evolving
Indian policymaking is a lot more
spaghetti ish than well thought through
policymaking so that comes with its own
can of worms but it continues to evolve
as these plays go for the local payment
networks so Visa and MasterCard for
example are today lobbying India through
the US government because India now has
domestic payment network which replaces
Visa and MasterCard
which are just 1/10 of the merchants
discount rate so what Visa and
MasterCard would give you for a percent
25 percent 50 gets done at 0.15 percent
and that is largely as a way to move
payments digitally which I'm a big fan
of stuff like that but then somebody
else has to pay the price in this case
we send MasterCard Amazon has been
prevented from doing private label and
I'm just giving you examples by the way
because I found these interesting so if
you I don't know if you know which is
the largest battery manufacturer and
supplier in this country and he gets in
the u.s. any other guesses Tesla is both
in terms of wattage and in terms of
number of batteries produced so Amazon
basic is bigger than Duracell
not even by basis points and that is
turning out to be the case in cables
it's turning out to be the case in
several other sectors so if you have all
the data of who's buying what at what
price where it makes sense that and the
boundaries that in traditional retail
private label would be 30 percent of
what you sell why because people come to
your stores so if you become a hundred
percent of what you sell they don't like
your store you become gap as opposed to
Macy's
so in the physical world there was a
natural boundary to how far private
label would go in the virtual world
there is no boundary to half our private
label can go so Amazon is wiping out the
battery business in the US the Indian
government has taken steps to say no
e-tailer
will both sell their own products and
own the store and there are variations
of this and by the way this is a lot
more nuanced so please don't confuse
this as me being a vehement supporter of
all regulations there are some pretty
screwed up ones also but the bottom line
is this this
the whole process is evolving there are
some very interesting initiatives for
example there are open API is to get a
lot of government data so there are
interesting companies being built around
data aggregation of that FinTech space
as I mentioned to you already
immigration policies here are actually
helping India I go regularly to recruit
people from colleges the number of
people who are willing to now apply for
an advanced degree through a combination
of both more domestic opportunities and
the fear that they will be replaced
refused a visa is now down in the single
digit percentages and I am talking about
the IITs at this point in time I came
here 30 year ago eighty percent of the
class came here at this point in time
IIT Kanpur CS 3 people came out of a
class of 70 so I think it is good for
the country I don't think it is that
good for for us here and I go between
both places so I am totally muddled it's
a growth bit that we discussed not
present market size and the ecosystem
dynamics that you see here are present
there also while we are in a virtual
world physical proximity works and
Bangalore is becoming the stronger and
stronger player it used to be 33 3333 in
favour of Bangalore Delhi Mumbai today
Bangalore is easily 50 percent of
everything that gets done in the startup
space
in India and that feedback loop is very
powerful and talent money support
advisors they all feed into each other
some components I rushed I run through
this quickly talent we've talked about
one and a half million new engineers
graduate every year on the downside most
of them are not hireable so hopefully
one solves that problem and you get more
supply the numbers are still meaningful
but if you believe one and a half
fantastic engineers you got another
guess coming hungry the aspirational and
reality gap is very large so it produces
enormous amount of both risk-taking and
drive as you must have read about this
nine nine six thing in China those of
you this is work from 9:00 a.m. to 9:00
p.m. six days a week it's not that bad
in India but you see a lot of hunger
among a lot of the people who start
companies social norms have moved in
favor of entrepreneurship especially
after parents read in the newspaper that
somebody made a billion dollars they
tell their child you should become an
entrepreneur as opposed to you must go
get a government job which was the norm
even a decade and a half ago I used to
go to people's homes to reassure their
parents that we will be in business so
please let your child work for my
company it's no longer the case cost of
talent is lower we've gone we've gone
through attitude and skilling and not
enough architects and managers this is a
very interesting dynamic especially for
those of you who think of opening
offices in India the traditional talent
has been AB development because services
companies there would be one architect
who would drive a team of 50 60 70
developers those developers were
basically told do as you are told and
even if the chair is missing a leg
that's okay we'll make more money
because on the revision cycle for adding
that check that chair leg and we will
get more money so there was not a
premium for getting the product right it
was delivered on the basis of service so
you ended up with a lot of premium on
becoming a manager not on a senior
technical contributor at an individual
level that trend has started reversing
over the last five six seven years so
the natural time that it takes for
people to become strong individual
contributors is the gap that you see
today so if you start a high-end
security company in India you will have
two very good founders who understand
the ins and out of security when you
want to hire the next level
pardon my french you're screwed then you
start with a whole bunch of junior
people or you get to three people you
can't build a critical mass of 20 high
quality people that is changing but is
not yet there
okay and by the way this is not meant to
either talk you in favor off or
otherwise this is a rendition of at
least the way I see facts don't take
them for or don't take them too
seriously
market it's a growth market and across
the board we went through all of that a
capital one of the things working in
favor of India is there is too much
money in the world and as long as people
keep printing it it needs a place to go
to and India is a very interesting
destination along with a whole bunch of
others so you will find a lot of money
coming to India in addition to a whole
bunch of the other fact
that's worth calling out just a few
comments and exits actually this also
we've gone through oh this is one other
interesting factoid I was looking at the
number of unicorns unicorns defined as
privately traded companies greater than
a billion dollars in somebody's view
somebody meaning somebody wrote a check
so there are 125 in 125 in China is it
so China at least this Vikki PDF page
careful about counting yeah okay I see
wide variation in the numbers so please
take all of these figures with a grain
of salt
absolutely so the numbers that I got
from a Wikipedia page were 25 in India a
hundred in the US and 125 in China and
then I started going through the ones in
India and I disagreed with at least five
because I happen to know the companies
I'm an invested in one of them and the
company is bankrupt so how it is being
counted as a unicorn I have no idea
so clearly the numbers are somewhat
suspect but as a as a rough guess if one
were to even take this factor of
potentially gee I think that is right in
terms of how people look at it but even
that pig can be dressed up so roughly
the point that I was trying to get to
though is not as Professor dash has said
to take those numbers too seriously but
to take the trend seriously if you
looked at how many large market cap
companies existed in India even five
years ago it was probably a fifth of
this so if I were to summarize the whole
thing I view the whole country as a
start-up okay and what are the
characteristics of a startup you bet on
the first derivative not on the absolute
values and for those of you who forgot
remember the first derivative is the
growth absolute value is the size so
it's not that it's a two trillion dollar
economy it's you
build a business that can grow
significantly faster than what you could
do in a whole bunch of other places so
it's a start a bet that is why you join
a startup IBM you get fired for a 500k
account in a startup you get carried on
the shoulders of everybody for a 500k
account so that's the kind of dynamic
that is there so it becomes possible to
raise money it's also possible to lose a
lot of money actual domestic dollars are
small venture industry blah blah blah as
us players dominate and the last one is
there are it's like a barbell there are
companies that if the fundraising skills
are fantastic you can justify losing
money with the 10 year picture in mind
which was what we were talking about
because then you are showing everybody
in this picture winner will take all
come with me
it requires fundraising skills
operationally you don't have to worry
about it because whether you are losing
10% or 12% who cares its fundraising
games and those people who are not able
to raise funds that effectively will
that is not a core competence there are
lots of much smaller opportunities out
there 100 million dollar businesses
galore so at least the way I think of it
is as this barbell one peg to raise and
burn large amounts of cash the other peg
to be okay with the smaller exit but
that will still do fairly well on a
returns basis if one is disciplined so
end of the deck thank you very much
so I do want to spend a little more time
in Q&A but I want to kind of ask the
first one yes it so you had about three
or four billion dollars of funds raised
in venture capital
yeah do you think that is about right
for the amount of investing that there
is or do you think that it should be a
lot more is it is there a real scarcity
of venture capital or is this really
kind of too much money pushing too few
deals so I think there are multiple ways
of asking what is right one is are you
getting the returns invested because for
example in the u.s. 75% of the venture
funds return less than zero
so if you give hundred bucks to a
venture fund 75 percent of them will not
give you a buck back okay yet a whole
bunch of people made a lot of money in
the u.s. so my sense is that I think in
India the amount of money that is there
is actually less than what the country
needs largely because there is a huge
hole in the mid stage of investing so
companies that want to raise series B
Series C funds in India have an
inordinately hard time you can get
early-stage money because there is a
fairly vibrant angel community and by
the time you are succeeding and growing
very large a whole bunch of foreign
investors come in you don't even rely on
domestic capital the likes of Softbank
Tiger global there are a whole host of
people who come in which is not counted
there by the way you know so it's this
mid-level stuff that is that is missing
and does that have to do with what
happens to attitudes about investing in
growth versus absolute size or what why
is it missing so I think part of it is
just the maturity cycle okay where to
start writing those kinds of checks you
need people who have had some success
writing smaller checks and those people
are growing up that is one part of the
dynamic and I think the other one is
tied to exits people will be willing to
create larger funds once they have seen
money coming back which is one of these
timing cycles there you have to wait for
810 years and there will be some
casualties on there delivering so I
think from a timing perspective it's
hard to get funds in all stages of
capital right ideally yeah and therefore
it's a natural phasing okay there's one
other area that I really want to address
and partly because of our presentation a
couple of weeks ago and it's the rich
and poor gap among the general
population right so are you seeing that
as something that's getting worse or is
it improving
are the motivations for developing new
companies not b2b but on the b2c said
are they really looking at addressing
basic needs or what are they more
technology driven though not you so in
my view it is not improving as quickly
as
I would like but I think all of us would
like it to be better than whatever it is
right now
so that becomes a tautology at one level
but I do think even at fundamental
levels the growth in GDP is lower than
what is needed to deal with so for
example India has about 15 million
people who come out of some kind of an
educational system every year of that
about 11 to 12 do not have a job that
engages them for the education that they
received and this is not a
straightforward problem either here or
there or anywhere to solve yeah so I
think it is growing slower than I think
at least what I would like if you were
to believe official numbers they hover
around seven to eight percent if we were
to compare it to China during the stage
that they were getting out of this stage
of poverty one definitely needs
double-digit percentage growth and Here
I am just parroting this is not because
of a deep understanding it's because of
having read maybe one too many articles
the size of the market growing it's all
growing in the it's not so I think is
you you're going to find there is yet
another class of companies which as you
pointed out one class there is one of
the class of companies that I
consciously didn't address this time
which is the number of young people who
are looking to make a difference is
refreshingly large and I am really
really glad that there are not more
people like that there are many more
people unlike at least what my
motivations were when I was their age if
there is I think they are in good hands
social entrepreneurs people who are even
in large companies but give large
amounts of time and how do you apply
technology to solve more fundamental
problems and it is not just Google
getting impressed by 2/3 these
significantly large number of people
with good education there are at least
10 alums from Stanford that I know who
finish their undergraduate degrees and
have gone back and are working in stuff
which is not going to make them wealthy
but they're at it but very much helping
society that's right let's open before
number of especially with the last 3-4
years very very interesting Agrotech
companies that are coming about and a
couple of them just raised money to the
tune of 100 million dollars each which
would indicate that there is serious
excitement one of our companies does
something in Agrotech and that also gets
divided up and my understanding is thin
so please take this under advisement a
lot of it is going in the logistics part
of just because stuff gets produced it
gets wasted so there is warehousing and
logistics is a big part which is where
one of our companies is making
significant investments and they're
reaping rich benefits this is the big
basket the company that provides that
delivers groceries to your house they
have vertically integrated back to the
farm because they find that it makes a
huge difference to your unit economics I
don't know how many people are doing
stuff around better water management or
better seed management stuff I just
don't have an idea there I have more
visibility into the logistics and
warehousing piece thank you yeah so this
is the Stone Age place on the FinTech
space as compared to India sorry I was
first over cash so sorry go ahead
seems like you need stronger
stronger technical skills is the
assumption right or to be the founder or
help me with that because the answer is
both but that is too easy and trite and
answer so I want to understand a little
more about what you had in mind to be
happy I guess to be a founder or to be
earning a lot of money
ganya so different answers to one and
two meaning founder versus earning a lot
of money
founder might never burn any money so
it's not the best way to maximize gain
from credibility perspective so at least
there I have a slightly different view I
think it depends upon the company if
you're starting a company targeting dev
tools every founder better understand
coding because the product definition
starts from your customer is a developer
if you're starting a consumer internet
company somebody better understand go to
market using mass media kinds of things
marketing if you're starting an
enterprise sale company
you better have a tech founder who can
defend the nuts and bolts of what you
are building and a sales oriented person
who can make sure that you are building
the right thing so I think the answer is
more contextual several of the problems
as you correctly pointed out in India do
not rely on deep tech if they're going
after the domestic market if they're
going after the US market all of this
applies if you're going after the
domestic market it is not a deep tech
problem so indeed you are better served
with having better product management
user interface or business skills you
can get away with rubber bands chewing
them for much longer if you are building
the consumer product people can get away
with losing transactional data they
don't really care as long as you're not
selling them stuff if you're talking
your media stuff like I'd even get away
for a much longer distance so indeed
that would apply for domestically
focused companies given the stage of
evolution once you get to scale you
better get those people in otherwise
no no no unfortunately that dieter
doesn't take us anywhere booth Sachin
and Binny for developers at Amazon
Sanji Beach and Annie used to teach at
IMM devar Heath ish was an engineer turn
so they're that data unfortunately is
all over the map
so we can't that points our pcs in the
USA will be more interested in investing
in Indian company or the visas from the
India opportunity and I'll dig deeper
into that so if you look at somebody
who's sitting here
this place has enough and more
opportunity so there is very little
motivation for a VC here to go hunting
in India okay
there is also a higher level building
block when you go out and raise money
from people so for example when I raised
money from so Stanford is one of my
investors they would ask me so what are
you going to do and I tell them oh I'm
going to go invest in Indian companies
they have a different person who will
talk to me then the person who tells
them I am going to sit in the valley
this is very important by the way why am
I saying this because the source of
capital decides that they want to put 1%
in emerging market 5% in the valley 6%
in buying wood 20% making sense so for a
person to wander off wherever there is
opportunity triggered slapped by the
people who gave them money because now
they have muddled the Charter that they
had been entrusted with to begin with am
I making sense so there is that one
fundamental dynamic that your boss tells
you stay in place a play center not
defense then there is a second question
which is the person here and the west
coast in particular is tournament half
hours it's designed to inflict pain if
you want to work across India they don't
want to go hunt there because there is
an
of opportunity what ends up happening is
that companies get funded in India then
when they want to come to attack the US
market that is when they come to us
investors and tell them look I have some
evidence that I can address this market
now I would like to take that is for
economical reasons so in that case what
is the trend you see my definition of
whether a company is a US company or in
India Company and this is again a matter
of eye of the beholder
my diffusion is where is the CIO's it
then it's a US company then they could
be developing code on the moon for all
you care okay because then the people
here will say we have comfort in the
person who holds the bag this person
will therefore come here and this
clearly is a definition that can be
debated that is my definition wherever
the CEO sits that is where you will find
most efficacy they would move the
definition of focus because I don't
think we'll close this answer which is
why I qualified it right up front that
this is my definition it is subject to
debate it's you had a question
oh yeah so I tell you what I think we're
getting close to the end of the time of
the session we've got some refreshments
outside and and I think there are a
number of conversations to continue at
this point but first of all please join
me in thanking Ashish very much thank
you okay we'll clear the room and go out
and have something to eat and drink